hey guys it's justine and as you know i
have got my new macbook and i'm so
excited about it but of course we're
gonna need to get some accessories to
really trick this thing out so a huge
thank you to logitech for sponsoring a
portion of this video we have got a new
keyboard to check out and why i'm so
excited about this is not only will it
work with my mac but it'll also work
with my ipad this is the mx keys mini
for mac this is the master series by
logitech they also
sent me a mouse to go with this and not
only did they send this silver slash
white version they also sent me a pink
one all right so here's the keyboard
and the mx anywhere three mouse four mac
and of course look at this the pink
looks so good
look at this
step one turn it on connect to bluetooth
and download the mx setup software this
is cool you can set up some easy switch
so i can connect it to my computer or my
phone or tablet
mastered for mac okay so the first thing
that i noticed is there's an emoji
button that is very very important
little charging cable usbc
[Music]
look at you
the thing that i'm excited about this is
i am actually going to be traveling for
the holidays
so i always like to bring a keyboard and
a mouse home to my family's house so
this is gonna be great to just put right
in my backpack oh that's nice look at
that
love it
another usbc cable
let's check out this pink one what's
great about this one is this one is
either mac or pc so they have the keys
to correspond with either keyboard
layout
look at this one oh it's pink and
beautiful so this keyboard layout isn't
specific to mac it actually has the
option and start key and the command and
alt right here so this can also be used
for your pc which is where i think i'm
gonna put this one actually
oh that's a nice type
we've also got the matching mouse
oh
there it is
this one has a little bluetooth
accessory that you would plug into your
computer so i really like this keyboard
so far just because it does have a very
compact nature and i like these kind of
concaved keys because it fits right at
my fingertips i also like that it has
the emoji button we've also got the mic
mute and a dictation button let's turn
this on
oh it's also backlit i don't know if you
guys can see it because it's very bright
in the studio but i love the backlit
keys
now that it's unboxed let's go get this
hooked up in my office and as a note i
just started setting up my office so
this is kind of a very temporary setup
it is extremely functional but this
cable management is
an absolute disgrace
[Music]
everything is all connected to bluetooth
and here we are i like that this has a
scroll wheel on it and it also has some
customizable side buttons which is very
nice let's do a nice little
keyboard typing test
okay so my typing test went very well i
love the feeling of this keyboard so far
let me do a quick little editing test
and see what it's like to edit with this
mouse i do edit a lot with keyboard
shortcuts so that's gonna be very very
important for me
nice nice
all right
the typing and editing test
two thumbs up i also like that it has a
dedicated do not disturb button
like that is definitely key
notifications don't want to see them
very excited about my new addition to
the office if you guys want to check out
this keyboard and the mouse i will put a
link in the description where you guys
can get more information or purchase one
thank you again to logitech for
sponsoring a portion of this video so
let's talk about the rest of my mac
accessories now everything is being
powered by the new macbook pro 16 inch
and this thing is so incredible i
absolutely love it these pro display
xdrs are hooked directly into the
macbook but what's really powering
everything is this owc thunderbolt dock
now why i love this is i don't need to
plug in this computer like it is not
only powering the laptop but it's also
connecting all of my accessories i have
four different drives that are actually
connected to this thunderbolt dock i
love this because it also has an audio
output it does have an sd card slot and
it has various thunderbolt and usb ports
that i can have access to it's really
nice just having this one central hub
that everything goes through speaking of
things that are plugged into the hub
this is one of my favorite travel drives
this is the envoy pro ex and this is a
thunderbolt 3 drive i have edited so
many things off of this i always put all
of my footage on here when i'm on the go
because this is actually four terabytes
so i can fit a ton of content on here
also plugged into this thunderbolt dock
are two different thunderblade drives
now these drives are actually raid
drives so i have one that is an eight
terabyte raid and the other is a 16
terabyte raid and i have edited 8k
content off of this directly on those
drives and these are actually daisy
chained to each other so while they are
plugged into the thunderbolt dock
they're actually plugged into each other
and then they're connecting to my
computer now the main sort of storage
solution that i've been using right now
is this this is the thunderbay flex and
this is what i've been actually using to
store all of my completed projects and
all of my archived footage this actually
has 75 terabytes of usable storage so i
have plenty of space for past projects
i've got my coffee cup
which i'm actually drinking some sort of
like
weird powdered greens that is supposed
to be healthy but man does it taste
rotten moving on this is the elgato wave
3 microphone i used to use this for
gaming all the time but i love it
because it's usbc and it has some on
microphone controls looks like i might
have a little food on there too but
that's um that's the kind of person i am
when i'm not using speakers i do like to
always test my audio on my videos on
headphones so these are the airpods max
which i love we also have one of the
logitech brio webcams i used to use this
all the time for live streaming but i
did move it over here and connected it
to the macbook since i don't have a
webcam built into the pro display xdrs
so this is perfect for conference calls
so that's really kind of the whole setup
this is basically what i use and if i'm
not connected here i've really been
loving just being able to unplug
everything and take this macbook with me
i do also have one of the sony cf
express card readers so that's just also
connected to the dock and i know those
exciting feature in the new macbook was
having a built-in sd card but i don't
really ever use sd cards anymore
it's like
a stab
right there it's like oh yeah great
thanks now now you put it back what
about the last six years well thank you
guys for watching i'm so looking forward
to you guys coming along on this new
journey of setting up the new studio i
have so many fun things planned so i
can't wait for you guys to see all of
what we do with this incredible space if
you guys haven't already be sure to
subscribe and hit the bell so you'll be
notified when i post new videos and
leave me some comments below if you have
any suggestions for things that you
think that i should do in this space
i'll see you guys in the next video bye
[Music]
you